an old man once told me he said to
me I was trying to I was trying to
rationalize something I was trying to
make something an excuse for something I
was trying to make myself better than I
was I was trying to say it was
okay and and he just looked at me and he
he he liked me and he said
Teddy ain't no such thing as being a
little
pregnant
like yeah because either you're pregnant
or you're not
pregnant either you're real you're not
real either
you're you know truthful or you're not
truthful either you're tough or you're
not tough either you're either you're
you know committed or you're not
committed either you're in or you're
out that applies a lot of things yeah
including
loyalty that's quite a statement but the
life blood of humanity from me is
loyalty um it's it's what goes through
the veins of uh you know everything has
to have some veins in some form and if
Humanity has veins what runs through the
veins of humanity instead of blood to
keep it alive is
loyalty without loyal without loyalty
with dead we freaking walk with with
vessels I never understood what a ghost
ship was you know what as I got old I
know what a ghost ship is it's people
it's people that are empty they got no
loyalty
therefore they got no
Humanity therefore they got
nothing therefore freak them freak them
because and and and you know why they
don't have loyalty convenience and you
know
why because it takes it's hard to be
loyal it's actually hard I'll be a son
of a gun yeah you tell me yeah it sounds
great give it to me give it to me paint
me with it yeah it's great yeah I'm
loyal I'm yeah I'm great I'm yeah this
is good I'm ready I'm on that team I'm
ready put me in coach I'm ready okay now
you have to uh you're going to have to
get hurt here what do you mean get hurt
oh well it's going to be painful I mean
to be loyal you know you you're going to
be in danger because the person that you
committed your loyalty to for a reason
because obviously he did something in
your life whatever whatever
um you're actually going to get hurt to
be loyal to him you're actually going to
hold on a minute wait hold on coach
um hold on call time out here um let me
think about this coach I'm I'm I might
need more more practice I'm not ready
for the game I'm not ready to go in the
game yet give me a little more practice
coach and it hurts to be loyal it
freaking hurts but without
loyalty we's we're ghost ships we got no
strength we got nothing yeah we got
nothing we we got we got
nothing